und da waren wir überraschend schon in
berlin bin ich verbunden mit carsten
linnemann cdu stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender der unionsfraktion
im deutschen bundestag und gleichzeitig
vorsitzender der cdu mittelstands union
herr lehmann darf mal davon ausgehen ich
grüße sie in die hauptstadt dass sie die
zweite kandidatin runde verfolgt haben
wer hat sie überzeugt erst einmal auch
grüß gott oder guten morgen frau an land
hier aus berlin ich habe die
kandidatenrunde verfolgt also am ende
des tages muss man wirklich sagen wir
haben drei starke kandidaten
das ist einfach so wir haben einen
tollen wettbewerb erlebt und das sollte
man jetzt nicht in den letzten tagen
kaputt machen durch welche äußerungen
auch immer und deshalb möchte ich als
erstes betonen dass wir wirklich drei
starke kandidaten haben wir als
mittelstandsunion haben uns für
friedrich merz ausgesprochen aber der
delegierte selbst kann natürlich für
sich entscheiden und da wird natürlich
nichts vorgegeben auch das ist wichtig
in einer volkspartei
beim digitalen parteitag wäre
wahrscheinlich alles andere auch gar
nicht so einfach zu prüfen
herr lehmann wenn wir einfach jetzt
schauen die personen die nach ak kommt
und den parteivorsitz ausfüllen soll was
wären die drei haupteigenschaften die
müsste dieses profil aussehen sie müsste
klarheit haben in der sprache erstens
sie müsste zukunftsgerichtet sein
wir müssen als volkspartei für die
zukunft stehen und nicht für die
vergangenheit dessen was wir bereits
gesehen haben
und drittens er muss vereinen können vor
allem es gibt einen tag nach dem 16
januar und an diesem tag es ist
unglaublich wichtig dass die partei dass
die union als ganzes zusammenhält
ansonsten werden wir ein problem
bekommen im bundestagswahlkampf
die zeit drängt es sind noch ein paar
monate bis zur bundestagswahl
und umso wichtiger ist es dass der neue
vorsitzende einen kann und nicht spalten
wenn es nicht falsch gelesen habe muss
man sogar noch ein bisschen mehr geduld
haben und bis zum 22
januar wenn tatsächlich diese briefwahl
noch ausgeschöpft ist dann formell
warten aber lassen wir das mal dahin
gestellt
sie haben das gerade schon angesprochen
das ist eine freie entscheidung selbst
sie mit ihrer
vereinigung geben es frei die umfragen
sagen alles ist sehr eng würden sie
dennoch eine prognose wagen
1001 delegierten der schweiz wirklich
sehr schwierig voran und ich meine sie
kennen das auch sie sind auch sehr lange
im geschäft früher hat man sich
getroffen
auch mal abends sind kleiner runde auch
mal auf ein glas bier wie stimmst du ab
wie stimmt der ab wie sieht es in dem
landesverband in der bezirks situation
aus und all das ist jetzt nicht möglich
natürlich telefoniert man aber man
kriegt immer nur punktlandung in dem man
an einem tag mit jemandem telefoniert
meine prognose ist die dass es heute
noch nicht feststeht dass viele
delegierte wirklich am wochenende
entscheiden
und vielleicht kommt es auf die an
genauso haben wir es auch erlebt vor
zwei jahren als frau kramp karrenbauer
gewählt wurde
herr lindemann wir müssen im grunde
genommen die eine frage beantworten und
die anderen noch im blick behalten
zumindest ihre delegierten müssen dass
und wir können es heute morgen hier tun
die frage ist die k frage die dahinter
steht also ganz klar ist bisher gewesen
kann man sagen dass der
cdu-parteivorsitzende auch den ersten
zugriff auf die kanzlerkandidatur haben
wird wird es so bleiben absolut frau
allein das ist so das geht bis in die
kreispartei natürlich hat derjenige der
einer partei vorsteht ob im kreis oder
im bund erst mal ein recht zu
kandidieren und auch die besten chancen
in der formel 1 nennt man das pool
position aber dieser vorsitzende muss
sich natürlich noch bewähren wir werden
vermutlich erst im frühjahr den
kanzlerkandidaten wählen ist ein ist
dann auch noch zeit und wenn dieser
kandidat bis dahin keine großen fehler
macht die partei nennt nimmt klar in der
sprache ist zusammenhält dann glaube ich
bin ich feste dinge dass dieser kandidat
dann auch kanzlerkandidat der gesamten
union wird der umfragekönig bei es ja
markus söder was zum beispiel die k
frage angeht aber auch ein anderer name
oder in den letzten tagen sehr häufig
genannt er ist mit corona verbunden ihr
gesicht von corona jens spahn der selber
von sich sagt er traut sich alles zu sie
ihm auch die ersparnisse ein glücksfall
für unsere partei
wir brauchen solche typen wie hier
entspannen die zukunft gerichtet sind
aber er ist auch nicht naiv und weiß
dass der neue vorsitzende die besten
chancen hat kanzler zu werden oder
mindestens kanzlerkandidat und deshalb
setze ich mich dafür ein und
unterstützen auch wenn er dann
stellvertretender parteivorsitzender
werden will oder eine herausragende
position nicht nur in der partei sondern
vielleicht auch in der regierung wenn
man da unterstützen kann in der
zukünftigen wenn es die dann gibt mit
union ich hoffe dass und insofern bin
ich guter dinge dass hier in spa noch in
zukunft eine wichtige rolle in unserer
partei spielt dieser montag ist ein
wichtiger montag für deutschland weil
und die beiden das thema jetzt sozusagen
auf krone haben aber mit jens spahn
schon den anfang gemacht weil sich jetzt
noch mal zeigen wird dass föderalismus
durchaus eine sehr gute sache ist aber
auch sehr kompliziert sein kann
beim wähler kommt dass schon wieder ein
wenig diffus an was jetzt sozusagen in
den verschiedenen ländern gilt hätte
politik da nicht vernünftiger agieren
können was heißt vernünftige agieren
controller und die krise zeigt die
probleme dieses landes oder
herausforderungen auf ich bin der festen
überzeugung wir brauchen eine
föderalismusreform
das muss in zwei programm meiner partei
föderalismus ist an der einen stelle gut
weil es wettbewerb erzeugt wer ist der
beste wert die besten konzepte aber wenn
es um punkte geht
das beispielsweise wir deutschlandweit
eine lernplattform brauchen damit der
unterricht der nicht im präsenz
stattfindet jetzt digital stattfindet
wenn wir das nicht schaffen dann müssen
wir uns die frage stellen was müssen wir
reformieren und deswegen um am beispiel
bildung zu bleiben bin ich der festen
überzeugung wir brauchen eine
bildungsreform gebrauchen eine
föderalismusreform dass es
bundeseinheitliche standards gibt und
dann kann gerne an der einen oder
anderen stelle wo es nicht um eine
plattform gibt und eine
bundeseinheitliche regelung das land
voran gehen aber ich glaube das zeigt
die krise das brauchen wir jetzt das
nehmen wir mit deutschland braucht eine
föderalismusreform vielen dank für diese
klaren ansagen heute hier carsten
lindemann im phoenix tagesgespräch
stellvertretender fraktionsvorsitzender
der unionsfraktion im deutschen
bundestag und vorsitzender der
mittelstands otto dankt nach berlin nach
sie danken frau an land
mal